[Music]  you want to come in and give me some  fabulous commuter beauty tips yes I can  meet her beauty all the time I do  everything till the last second I'm  running around with my hair on fire all  the time I love a roll-on sunscreen yes  you should try these it's so good it's  great because even on top of makeup oh  it doesn't dry just roll it on the  roll-on on ones I find are like even  higher SPF this is SPF 50. the factor  always represents how much longer you  can actually stay in the sunshine  sometimes I make excuses to not wear SPF  because I love being tan and you can  still get time with it yeah it's a thing  can you yeah you can okay good it's not  complete blockage I gotta say have never  worn sunscreen in my life because it  always breaks me out mineral based is  what you need if you break out and it  also stops you clogging too much okay  guys we want to know your favorite  beauty tips using the hashtag Community  Beauty it's all about on the go life